this is two amp fuse whites it's copper
tinned copper wire which is used to be
used in old-fashioned fuses and george
has this long bit of fuse wire which
he's
hung between two electrodes you probably
can't see so we put some paper on this
wire and you see the line across there
and then it comes along here so this is
a wire which is jittering a bit because
i i don't know why because
you just leaned into the
all right it's hanging there in the
shape which doesn't seem to be
particularly special now i'm going to
turn the current on this is
volts going up and this is the current
in amperes so it go all the way up and
this goes up to 1.8 amps roughly 1.75
so this is below the point where the
fuse wire will melt
so now i'm going to do the experiment
i'm going to turn the current on
and here it goes
up to 1.8 amps and now i'm going to turn
it off
on
off
it's reversible it goes up it goes down
on
off
one
off when the current's on
it goes through the fuse wire and
because of the resistance of the fuse
wire it heats up that's what a fuse wire
is for it's meant to heat up and melt
when you get up to about 200 degrees
centigrade this gets up somewhere near
there
so we're not
melting this we're just heating it up
quite a bit
and as we heat it up it expands and you
normally can't see the expansion of a
metal when you heat it up but here you
can
so this sagging in the middle is due to
the fact that the wires got a little bit
longer less than one percent
increase in length will cause it to sag
by that amount so this is a measure of
the current going through it and that's
first thing current leads to heat
changes the temperature leads to
expansion leads to sagging
now i've got another magic box
this is a magic box with an n on the top
because that's probably something to do
with north and
something else on the bottom south i'm
not meant to take this out george tells
me that if i take it out it will then
suck itself into anything and cause
great damage oh it's a magnet all right
here it is
another one of these neodymium magnets
it's very very strong and i'm very
clumsy with these things if you put it
near a piece of metal it will disappear
into it so now i've got a magnet
if i put this horizontally nothing much
happens but if i put it
this way
as i move the magnet towards
the wire you can see it's repelled quite
strongly
if i turn it round the other way
so now the north pole is at the bottom
it should pull in the other way can you
see that brady yeah
it comes and hits the magnet what's
going on
and if i put it horizontally not much
happens well there is a magnetic field
going this way
and when a current goes down the wire
this way that leads to a force on the
wire in a not in this direction not in
that direction but in the third
direction perpendicular to it and if i
turn the magnetic field around i change
the direction of the force so this is a
force between a moving charge
and a magnetic field which acts in a
funny funny way which you normally can't
see but here it's very graphic because i
got such a long strong magnetic field
you can actually see it being repelled
if i were to be a magician in the 19th
century 20th century and i wanted to go
on stage and fool people and i set this
up it would look as though i have magic
powers pushing it away
oh
float my beauty
if i now turn the current off
you have
a wire without any current and you have
no effect at all it is proportional to
the current
this is sagging a little bit it would
move if it could but it doesn't want to
because there's no current
pretty cool yeah i love this because i i
mean thermal expansion used to be one
experiment and you could never measure
it
and and this thing
the force on a moving current you could
never see it is so weak and now i can
see both because the magnet's so big so
this is this is
george again to the rescue this is
wonderful thank you george we're talking
about the rotation of the earth or other
objects and the effects of smaller